hey guys welcome back to the evident
limb podcast today we're gonna be
reacting to all of y'all's assumptions
about us oh my gosh they've been there
I've been so excited to get to this
podcast like there have been so many
great strange sometimes controversial
and it just generally interesting
assumptions yeah we we had probably 1500
ish assumptions submitted there's no
inga to all of them today we we tried to
break them down into various categories
but we're probably just gonna jump
around from category to category today
and if you guys like this podcast let us
know and we'll do episode 2 with more of
the assumptions because there's so many
good ones yeah assumptions about us our
home life our relationships I was like
all sorts of things yeah yeah so maybe
let's just start with the general
assumptions about us and honestly I
tried not to look at the assumptions too
much so I can be hit with all of this
fresh kaylynn organize it all but I did
see some and there's some interesting
like one listed out to be like Kalyan
has horse people energy there were so
many okay I wrote down a couple of them
but there were so many the car kind of
search for horse yo a search for horse
yeah okay so here we have one from
Conrad I think Caitlyn was a horse girl
at some point um there's several and
some related ones too from Dyess tree I
think Caitlyn was a farm girl from Ruby
I assume Caitlyn was a country girl so I
didn't really I don't know why it didn't
dawn on me because I've been watching
jenna marbles joke about how she has
horrible energy with her super long hair
that she never cuts and I never realized
that like I might also have horse people
energy haha but the thing is like I'm
not and have never been an actual horse
person horses kind of scared me when I
younger not gonna lie I've ridden one
maybe twice in my life I've ridden
horses more than Caitlyn why don't I
have horse people RG yeah people III
rode horses on mountains I've galloped
on that thrown off a horse I got thrown
off a horse off of a mountain yeah you
did well not all the way off not all the
way off down the mountain down the
mountain yeah um that's why I was scared
of them horses are very scary I always
thought that I had more cat people
energy because that's how I identify
myself you have that - no I was like you
don't have that person energy um I do
think there's also so many assumptions
about Caitlyn and cat that's like that
could be a whole podcast yeah I do think
part of it and this was um another
another assumption there are lots of
assumptions about my hair mmm so I
assume Caitlyn this from Daisy I assume
Caitlyn has had long hair her whole life
Haruki I assume Caitlyn has a really
crazy hair routine so I think this super
long hair is part of the horse people
energy it's actually more recent no I
mean I've always well not always for
most of my life I've had decently
long hair in middle school I chopped it
off and went for the Rachel from friends
cut even though I did not watch friends
at the time I didn't watch it till I was
an adult and then in college I chopped
it off to where it was like like a very
short Bob you look good with a bob thank
you thank you it was I dyed it black I
had a short bob and bangs definitely had
a crush on her yeah you did it that day
no I know I had a crush on you at that
time was that the beginning of it was
junior junior it's all mixed up yeah
it's all mixed up um but yeah I think
those super long hair is part of the
horse people energy but so I I mostly
don't cut it because it's really
expensive to get your hair cut and I'm
very lazy I don't like putting any
energy into my hair and so like even
leading up to quarantine I hadn't cut it
like I had already put it off for a few
months and then everyone has to be
quarantined and so now
like down to my butt and I really want
to get it cut and like even my daddy one
available is me yeah
even my dad's like your hair is gonna
kind of long so I think we want to do a
video potentially wherever that's my
hair we just haven't had time to do it
yet it's also interesting that they
assume that you have a crazy hair
routine but you've actually like
efficiently optimized your routine to
the point where it's the least amount of
time needed to maintain good hair I've
trained my hair to where I don't
I like barely have to wash it ever yeah
and your curls last like a week yeah I
curl it like once a week I can count a
long time without washing it and I sleep
in buns two buns where I like twist it
in the same direction of the curls and
then so like if you're watching I know a
lot of people listen if you're watching
to the video or if you're if you're
watching the video on YouTube now I have
like some curls left over this probably
from like a couple days ago when I spent
about five minutes just curling the
front because we're about to stream in
the back is straight back is true but no
it's it's some very low maintenance
because I don't like putting timing yeah
I don't know why that stood out to me
probably cuz there's one of the top
voted ones and there's one of the only
ones I saw but that was pretty much what
were some of the ones that really stood
out to you well I want to do some Evan
specific ones oh here's what about your
hair this was the top the top yes the
top comment if I sort by top it's from
Phoenix
I assume Evan grew his hair out longer
just once
possibly a mullet or something similar
and it probably went well with the beard
not at all no but I didn't used to have
an afro I used to have a little bit of
an afro I mean yeah my hair has been
strange my entire life because when I
was really young like when I was a baby
it was more brown hair and then when I
was like seven or something I had kind
of straight blonde blondish hair
yeah and then as I hit puberty I had
dark curly hair like through college
yeah in college I was like curly hair
yeah and then at the end of college it
went straight again yeah your hair's
it's been on a journey but I've never
had long hair although during swim
practice once every year when we went to
districts and regionals and stuff we
would shave our arms shave our legs buzz
our hair and stuff so before we bust our
hair we would always do weird things to
our hair like I shaved like smiley face
into my friends like the back of his
head I dyed my tips blonde I did all
sorts of weird things to my hair because
I knew how to shave it off yeah after so
it's like might as well have fun for a
little bit and have strange hair and be
able to experiment with it and stuff
like that yeah so I think that was that
was my that's the extent of my hair
journey I have um like wondered what you
would look like with long flowing locks
hmm I wonder how I what awkward stages
I'd have to go through in order to get
long hair there would be awkward stages
where it's kind of like a bob imagine if
it was just like ah I'd have to do like
that's why people do the mando to get
through the awkward Bob stage I had to
go through the awkward Bob stage but I
was a girl when when you were growing it
out from your pixie cut to the normal
and growing out the bangs that's really
awkward because I had blunt bangs
straight across and so those just grow
out and like all your hair is long and
the rest your mouth or scent your chin
when the Bob - it's like it was like you
had longer here here and shorter hair at
the back yeah I'm gonna shorten spike
spikey in the back yeah so that was
probably the most awkward because normal
hair is longer in the back and short in
the front for like long cuts usually
shows what I know about hair maybe I
shouldn't have no it's gonna be fun UH
one thing that a lot of people a so
assumed very wrong thing that's about us
which is very interesting how much we
travel in our travel history yes Bethany
Smith said I assume that you guys rarely
take vacations or trips because it seems
like you're always so busy
I would say
that assumption currently oh yeah
currently currently is true the past few
years since we started the channel
mainly our trips have been work-related
so like collabs and events yeah but uh
let's see I assume that you guys were
the kind of people that went to a
landlocked honeymoon state from Kate V
we went to awesome they were on there
were several related travel ones of
people that thought we didn't are like
never last left Texas yeah or like
didn't um or like like grew up in one
place mmm mostly I think we've talked
about in a few past podcasts where we
talk about our past but we both lived in
about seven or eight places grown both
of us traveled a whole bunch when we
were growing up and I think I've been to
over 50 countries even though I haven't
made a list of them I actually started
making the list once and I was like
texting my parents and everything but so
much of the travel that I went on was
when I was like between 3 and 9 so I
don't remember a lot of it but we
traveled a lot yeah when I was younger
we mostly like traveled within the
States because we have a lot of family
well you have a lot of family spread out
too but because of your dad's job and
like allowed for international travel we
would travel decently around to like
visit family and friends but we didn't
move a lot so like I went to three
Elementary School's two middle schools
two high schools and you're probably
similar I did three middle schools one
highest three middle schools middle
schools only three years I did one
middle school for half a year one middle
school for one year and one for another
year and a half I don't know maybe I did
for middle school because I was moving
in the middle of the year and we moved
out once a year
so I might have done for middle schools
even though need three years that's
great your moves were more concentrated
than mine more concentrate I know more
we moved like every three years there's
a period there where we moved once a
year that's crazy I was crazy hobbies
interests oh and several gear moves like
you lived overseas I know we have
another podcast I'm not sure if everyone
yeah and in Dubai in the United Arab
Emirates and in Riyadh Saudi Arabia and
yeah lots of places yeah and in terms of
travel we used to take like a big
two-week vacation every year we'd save
up all of our vacation days yeah I think
our favourites were probably Thailand
and New Zealand yeah we I still would
like to travel but the main thing that's
changed is you know we used to really
like getting away from work and
traveling cuz it was an extended period
of time for us to hang out have
adventures have fun experience make
memories that will like last for a long
period of time and like you know all of
that jazz but but now we're kind of on
an adventure all the time creating
videos creating content spending time
together share new experiences like like
I think there's like a higher cost to
travel now too because we're working for
ourselves and so you know when you get
vacation days from work you just leave
yeah don't feel guilty about oh yeah
you're right
alright someone else someone else is
trying to deal with all of the worries
like this is what vacation is and I'm
gone but there's no one to take things
over for us because we are our business
so it's harder for us to share it off we
can do it for like a weekend we've done
a clear like small trips yeah alright so
we have an assumption from Mary that
where she assumes that Kaitlyn wasn't
into any of the nerdy stuff before she
met Kevin I would say like um we were in
we were both into some nerdy things that
overlapped and some things that didn't
overlap I mean we were both into nerdy
stuff like video games Pokemon anime
anime I'm oh yeah well what what even is
the definition of nerdy
anymore because nerdy the term nerdy is
like is it just like I'm into computer
programming and circuitry and like what
level of nerdiness does it count to be
especially when it's like pretty
mainstream these days yeah like if
someone's into Pokemon that everyone's
like oh you nerd and also nerd like used
to like I remember back in middle school
days like nerd was like a little bit of
a negative term but now it's I don't
think it is more associated with like
personality Arden no I like caring a lot
about how you did in school I was very
nerdy in that sense because I was like
very straight a I'd get my homework done
before in that sense you're way more
nerdy but I would say you're more nerdy
on the tech side of things
oh yeah like I enjoy tech a lot I just
like look at this tiny little computer
that I have I get so much joy from
having this little 9 inch computer in my
pocket sometimes so like I don't I
probably don't nerd out over tech as
much but I would say we're both decently
nerds Rebecca
Chavez says I assume you both have cause
played at least once I have cos played
well also - certainly we like her what
counts as cosplay versus just like
dressing up for Halloween yeah I think
like to cosplay it has to be something
homemade but you owe Tony Stark I even
shaved my mustache and everything like
Tony Stark facial hair I made the little
like pew pew wrist thing you know yeah
yeah and I did everyone I say nyan cat
even though I know what's wrong young
cat is that how you say it he also
partially did a Wonder Woman I would say
9 but we said that and we got corrected
but so I made like a pop-tart and
rainbow outfit yeah and like like for
the same convention that Caitlyn wore
than I am tattoo Oh
kind of lazy so I have a stormtrooper
helmet that's pretty cool so I just put
on a stormtrooper helmet my old
lifeguard shirt lifeguard trunks and I
was you know those stormtroopers had
problems sure have procedures in place
so to overwatch those recreational
activities so the stormtroopers who
can't swim have a lifeguard I wanted to
go and wear my costume oh one one one
thing that tons of people made
assumptions about our Heights yeah this
is so funny
I know it's so okay I think it's just
because there's a large difference
between us people get confused or
confused
so here's I'll just read two of the
assumptions from Caleb I assume that
Kaitlin isn't actually that small and
Evan is just a giant here's another
assumption from mavin Kaitlyn was one of
the shortest people in high school and
Evan was one of the tallest so Evan is
six-five Evan is a giant I am five six I
am rich - like maybe slightly on like
barely on the taller side yeah sure like
a female height yeah III was fairly
consistently the tallest person in my
age range all the time I think I was I
was 6 feet tall in middle school that's
pretty tall for middle school especially
cuz like most of like I remember being
taller than a lot of boys yeah in middle
school I played basketball not because I
had any skill in fastest just cuz I was
so much taller and I'll just stand under
the hoop and just catch the ball past
the people who can shoot and that's what
my utility was and I accepted that I
didn't play basketball that much I must
rather enjoyed swimming because it was
so hot in most of the places we lived
especially when I was growing up in the
UAE and swimming was much more enjoyable
than the sweaty sweaty outdoor sports
kind of related and I think I think that
these next assumptions are also often
often related to the height difference
from Abby this is all about our
effective ages from Abby I assume Evan
is older than Caitlin but it might just
be a weird social construct because he's
so much taller the beard I think it's
the fear it makes me seem so much older
when I shave my beard there is a period
in my in where I accidentally shaved it
if you scroll back in our social posts a
long way alcoholic quacks oh yeah you
can just go to YouTube yeah but like oh
man I look baby-faced without my beard
oh yeah
related from Caitlin I assume that
there's at least a five year age gap
between you and then from Christy I'm
assuming that Caitlin is much older than
Evan Bayh a lot that's something I hear
people think we get more comments of
people thinking that you are older than
me but maybe some people assume that
you're older because you're more
responsible and I'm more chaotic joy the
truth is I am three months older than
Evan and for three months out of the
year I get a make fun of Caitlin we the
same age we met in school freshman year
both of us freshmen so we're about the
same age I want to scroll down this is
actually no we'll just keep going in
order
should we go to some of the like
controversial T stuff oh yeah save that
for later know what we'll do like well
it's not really controversial but it's
kind of funny um let's go to the
drinking swearing dirty jokes
so from make shaped create I assume that
Caitlin is a wine drinker and Evan is a
beer drinker those would both be wrong
cuz they generally taste gross there is
one wine that we enjoyed a ton on our
engagement night that was delicious
couple beers but we like I know better
that the one that was that one wine yeah
we got a rarely ever like to be here
there was a couple beers when they're
really cold the um like little kind of
fruity ones oh yeah yeah like they get
them only when we come over yeah it's
like the pineapple beer I'm sorry those
of beer yeah and like back cuz we did
used to you know go out drinking and
stuff like in our earlier 20s and such
but even then we would be more likely to
get mixed
yeah and we both drink a decent amount
of beer but it was like because of
drinking games and thinking cause the
cheapest thing to drink yeah and but
like never fully enjoyed it
so gross so gross it came back on it
maybe we think it's so gross because
most of our beer drinking was drinking
games like the cheapest natty lights or
whatever like there's been a ping-pong
ball that was on the floor thrown into
it you know
[Applause]
I mean and we've I think Caitlyn has
drank more wine than I have I'm thinking
one story in particular that we're not
gonna share we use more wine for cooking
yeah
okay another assumption from spider
spider Jinja I assumed you guys didn't
drink or curse when I first started
watching not saying it's a bad thing
that you do either um so these days I
will say we don't really drink a time
mm-hmm um and I don't know if it's cause
like we're mostly just hanging out with
each other and we don't really need
alcohol to be like goofy or silly around
each other um sometimes like if we go on
a nice date we'll like share a fancy
drink well that's more for like the
fancy drink experience yeah I mean I
know that sounds weird but like you just
look at those drinks and you're like
what the heck yeah I kind of want to
taste like like a dad
melting pot they have like this yin-yang
drink white chocolate dark chocolate
like ridiculous stuff and I'm like
mainly cuz it sounds tasty yeah we don't
we don't drink a ton these days I think
we kind of got it out of our system a
little bit and we don't we don't curse
in our videos almost at all that was a
conscious decision that we because I try
to keep things family-friendly one
because like we want to be advertiser
friendly and just from a business
perspective yeah but to it's like you
know when we when we started our videos
it was something that like you know even
before we started the channel we were
telling everyone all of our family all
of our friends all of our coworkers
and like we knew that our grandparents
would be watching and our young nieces
and nephews and cousins would be
watching and it was like you know we
just decided to kind of play it safe on
the cursing front and also functionally
functionally I don't see how much it
adds like we can express pain sorrow
regret or just like maybe a slight bit
more of realness the one time that
there's a there's like two times where
we did curse in the videos and there
when I fell through the ceiling when you
fell through the ceiling I cursed and I
believed it and then there was once
where we were making the wooden candle
holders yeah and we were you made a sled
for the table saw yeah and you said it's
a really blank sled
oh yeah that's a descriptive yeah yeah
it was a really bad word sled yeah we
believed him out both times but um
off-camera we swear some I'd say like
also sometimes for projects on the bench
when I get really frustrated I would say
like I let loose with like I like some
f-bombs like when I'm like really upset
and frustrated probably like three times
a year when like it's normally if we
curse it's more it for in like a
humorous way yeah it's not really out of
like frustration like things because the
podcast we also want to keep family and
advertiser friendly but most of our
cursing is probably cuz we're like
quoting something funny or we're just
trying to like make each other laugh
yeah and like we we're definitely not
opposed to curse words why certainly not
I think that they're funny and I think
we watch has cursing yeah yeah but like
it's just that's just what we want our
content to be yeah because I think
long-term I think it's just this is kind
of smart I don't know yeah let's see
Winnie I assume you guys swear a lot
off-camera I think we already addressed
that
address yeah there's a couple some for
some of these I put just a couple
different the wild side of a creative
mind you all both secretly have dirty
minds we try to tone it down I'm saying
that we we like oh I go Lauren are
recording and like Haley has to cut some
things out but yeah we make dirty jokes
they're funny
there's though they're so funny there's
definitely like a side of both of us
that is kind of like the humor of a 13
year old boy yeah yeah like mostly most
of our dirty jokes are very immature
we'll leave summon we'll leave like some
sausage cheese heads or like will I cut
it just the right point or like example
of it where I probably cut it like left
in the most was the recent life hacks
video there are a lot of like things
that we said then we like looked at the
camera way to like keep it family
friendly boy entertaining for the adults
too yeah you know it's like if someone
understands that joke it's okay you know
yeah that's funny though yeah okay let's
move on to some some Caitlyn specific
and some Evans specific assertions so
this is from Emma I assume that Caitlyn
like me is one of those people that gets
really flustered and frustrated when she
gets angry I I do kind of yeah I would
say like I feel like so read and flushed
I I am I cry sometimes
yeah to like when I get flustered and
frustrated and wait and it just makes
you more flustered and frustrated and
it's the worst like in a professional
work setting and it's happened to me in
work settings like talking to bosses
before where like you get so frustrated
frustrated you get so frustrated trying
to like communicate what you're trying
to communicate and you're also like
stressed and worried about communicating
that thing and then like it doesn't take
much for that to turn into like holding
back tears and then
once that feeling starts then it's just
a downward spiral and then if the person
talking to you is like are you okay
don't cry then it's just like I'm not
sad I'm only cry like how many times has
it happened in your traditional
workspace first like where we're at now
not too much at your last job your last
job wasn't that bad it still happened
though I can think of like at least
okay so here's here's a silly story I
can tell so I worked in corporate
branding for a large company and I was
pretty new and the CEO of the company
was in our little marketing department
walking around and he needed help with
something and so he and the and the CMO
the cheap mark chief marketing officer
had come to me and they're like hey um
do you want to come can you are you
available for a meeting at this time so
we can discuss this like presentation
you know for the CEO of the company and
at that time there was a going-away
party for one of our fellow marketing
people who was leaving and I was like I
was like well I'm not free exactly then
because it's so and so's going-away
party um but I'm free like 30 minutes
after and I thought that was like a
polite thing to say cuz I didn't want to
be in my way about a previous commitment
and you know the CEO was like okay the
CMO who was like I was really cool with
ya he was really cool with all of us he
came up and he was like did you just put
off the CEO for for like an ice cream
social and I was like oh no that was
that that I was like a couple months
into working at this job and I started
getting really flex to cry kaitlin's
like radiating heat right now radiating
heat right now she doesn't like socially
I was recounting that story
oh that's great that's great yeah I'm
gonna go turn on the AC
all right I'll read I'll read one
assumption about me then while Kaitlyn
well Kaitlyn turns down the AC I assume
that Evan regularly gets lost but always
has a great attitude about it you know
it's kind of interesting two sides two
ways that can be interpreted getting
lost physically I almost never get lost
physically in terms of conversations and
thoughts yes that's true
yeah no but like I I so so frequently
get lost in thoughts and and I've it's
something I know about myself something
I accept about myself and it's something
that Kaitlyn now accepts too because she
loves me and she's great but what I've
learned to do especially if it's an
important conversation and it's
something that really only I only use
with Kaitlyn but like I'll say I have
feelings and thoughts about this thing I
don't yet have it solidified in my mind
it's just vague feelings so I'm going to
talk it out what I'm saying isn't final
and I'll eventually get to like the
final thought that I have and then we'll
like talk through and help me determine
my my thoughts yeah I think it's funny
when like like we'll both be working in
the office and you're like I'm gonna go
do this thing can you walk into the
garage to go do the thing and like ten
minutes later I'll get up to go do
something and I see you standing in the
garage doorway just looking long about
ten minutes
I haven't been standing in the doorway
pretending you've been standing for ten
minutes but you might have like gone in
got distracted done something else
and then realized like oh I don't like
oh you can do the thing and you're like
oh yeah all right like you know on the
way there I'll be like oh I need to
vacuum this oh let me put up this box
let me break this down let me organize
this I'm like I forgot what I was going
to
it happens to me too sometimes what
happens do you more a lot more yeah okay
I thought this one was funny
from Laura I assumed that evan is that
one white dude that wears shorts still
concerned about it like Evan sweetie are
you sure are you cold
like she's very concerned it's funny
she's been saying that for years
yeah yeah I know I don't like wearing
jeans much and I don't like wearing
closed-toe shoes that much although I
found a good pair of shoes that finally
fits me and I'm wearing closed-toe shoes
more yeah well yeah I'd always wear
flip-flops all throughout all year for
years mm-hmm you know what stopped me I
got I'm old now and I'm having back
issues when I wear flip-flops and that's
incredibly sad that's the reason it's
bad I'm trying to convince Evan to get
some slides like me that way like cuz we
both like fuzzy socks yes and when
you're in your fuzzy socks it's really
hard to put on flip-flops if you just
want to like pop into the garage real
quick and then come back inside
but slides it's where it's at Evan was a
it sounds like a good idea at the time
guy and then somehow burned off his
eyebrows from Cameron Floyd you haven't
burned off your eyebrows but you have
almost burned off it's interesting it's
interesting cuz I am that type of guy to
a small degree like I am the type of guy
who just like goes for ideas but I am
also very thoughtful about anything
dangerous yeah just because I think
people assume that you are more careless
than you are
yeah because like those are the parts
that make it into the video but the
hours and days and sometimes weeks of
careful planning that Evan does when
we're doing anything especially if
there's anything remotely dangerous
about it yeah I mean everyone doesn't
get to see also in my background I was
designing all sorts of things that
humans would interact with where safety
was required and a lot of my job was
stress testing them
with pressure with like like huge
hydraulic presses crazy rpm crazy rpm is
in like measuring things with with
thermal vision and adding pressure for
sensors all sorts of sensors and like
stress testing systems and engineering
background you know that's that's what
we do it's all about being safe and
preparing and also the industry that
we're in was very safety focused too so
that's just that's just my background so
yeah a lot of that is really interesting
for the video so we just cut it out yeah
cuz it's just a lot of like behind the
scenes preparing um I'm going to jump
there's a couple related ones all
related to us and our individual
families yeah from Gabriela I assume
Caitlin is the oldest child and Evan is
the youngest or maybe and only from
pineapple pie I assume they are both
only children from Harley rows Caitlin
is either an only child or a youngest
sibling and Evan has a younger sibling
it's so interesting this place it's also
so interesting why people assume these
things it's interesting like to like
yeah well you know what's interesting
everyone has like their um like there's
stereotypes about like oldest youngest
or middle children yeah and I feel like
we actually kind of fit the stereotypes
that I have in my head but I might have
them in my head because we fit them okay
so Caitlin is the oldest hi I am the
oldest child I'm the middle child Evan
is the middle child see so every
assumption about me was wrong yeah every
assumption about you was wrong hi I am
the oldest meaning in the stereotype
that I find is like kind of the Bossier
and I like at least in my sibling
relationship growing up I was definitely
kind of the Bossier but also like the
goody two-shoes kind of a little bit you
know like I was semi goody two-shoes but
you were also semi the oldest cuz you
and your older brother are just a year
and a half apart yeah but I think for
seven years that's true yeah but what I
think of her like a middle child
stereotype is actually kind of like
peacemaker
in a way like the oldest child is kind
of like stereotypically slightly boss be
slightly goody-two-shoes the youngest
child is stereotypically kind of spoiled
kind of the baby of the family and the
middle child is more of like like
doesn't demand as much attention from
the parents and is often the peacemaker
yeah that's what but that's just like
what the stereotype that I have in my
head I don't know if it's because of
that but we do kind of fall into those
roles a little bit yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's interesting um okay
we have several assumptions based around
like where we live and and being in
Texas and that's not so interesting well
one we haven't lived in Texas our whole
lives and we grew up all over the place
but it's interesting that just because
we're in Texas there are so many
assumptions about us yeah cuz of that
yeah and I will say like Texas is where
we've lived the longest not true you
know we went to college in Texas and
we've lived in Texas since college I'll
be at a couple different we've moved a
little bit within Texas yeah one
assumption is from Ranger Ranger wrath
that you guys off-camera have a strong
southern accent no whoa how do you speak
as how we speak I will say when I'm
around my mom's side of the family I get
a little bit more of a southern like
when I'm around granny yeah um from Heil
me my assumption you guys aren't true
Texans and don't enjoy things most
Texans and joy what would that be like
like I can think of some texts on things
that we do enjoy like I enjoy like
tex-mex
we love tex-mex um we like uh I don't
know I think of like tubing and stuff
like tubing's really fun we haven't done
it in years but we used to I feel like
to go so would like to go tubing um you
know I used to work at Fiesta Texas very
Texan I'm not sure what what like what
kind of lovely chibi I love a chibi yeah
well things Texans like things
axons love I don't know like we love
Bucky's does that count rate football
yeah things being bigger in Texas uh-huh
Chile I mean like I like Chile but I
like other all types of chilies I don't
know this is in Texas shape stuff now I
really care
tacos breakfast tacos breakfast tacos I
love it barbecue in Texas is really good
it's mostly a lot about we like is food
related and I think we generally like
being in a warmer state um this is
related to one question that I saw yeah
which is from mr. Xylon I assume you
guys are scared of snow but it's okay we
love you anyway I don't think we're not
scared of snow I like I like snow when
I'm on vacation yeah I like skiing I did
snowboarding I got okay at it but I
think skiing more Caitlin did a little
bit of snowboarding a little bit of
skiing I like skiing snowboarding was
painful painful um but I would say like
I don't I don't really like the idea of
living somewhere where you just have to
deal with heavy snow constantly
everything being wet all the time like
having to scrape ice off your car that
sounds super not fun but I wouldn't say
I'm scared of snow I would just say I
would assume to not live with it for a
large part of our year and I'd even
though there are I mean obviously the
heat in Texas in the middle of summer
sucks but I feel like it's easier to
deal with and snow you don't have to
like actively do that and you can still
be outside use oh yeah let's see we have
an assumption from Stephanie D neither
of you have lived in Texas your whole
life evan is more of a morning person
than Caitlin those are two different
assumptions yeah well we already
addressed the Texas one and I am NOT
morning I mean I know he gets up and
makes coffee I'd say one day out of the
week
I like can get out of bed before I do
fast semi fast yeah okay getting into
something slightly controversial we got
a question an assumption from Sonia Yost
you guys are more right-leaning than
left but you don't mention it on your
YouTube channel because I think most of
your audience leans to the left so this
is interesting
we got assumptions both ways yes some
assumptions thinking that we're more
left-leaning Democratic some that we are
more right leaning Republican I think so
we don't really talk about politics and
it's not something that like we want to
make a habit of talking about what we
are more left-leaning I think the reason
some people assumed we might be right
leaning is because we're in Texas or
maybe because like we don't talk well I
don't know why not talking about cuz
like they're outspoken people on both
sides and all over the place it's just
not something that you know really comes
up when for making videos
we're playing video games I think that
one thing that's kind of interesting
though is I think that in our videos you
would be more free to assume either
direction but I think that for some
reason if you saw us play video games
and you saw reacting to various
circumstances various characters various
themes you probably assume that we're
more left-leaning you'd probably assume
that were more left-leaning because
we're like we're being exposed to things
and reacting to them in certain ways and
you can judge you can make more
assumptions because we're being exposed
to more things whereas when we're in our
garage making soap we're only being
exposed to like what we are choosing to
expose ourselves to instead of like you
know random questions from chat or like
a game we've never played before yeah
yeah stuff like that that's that's
interesting yeah and that's just like
get all of the the controversial things
right out of the way right now I mean
it's it's funny like your political
leanings are like it's like
controversial especially right now to be
talking about it the next one isn't
again it's not really controversial
there's just something that we don't
talk about that's religion well I think
because
you know both of these subjects are so
complex it's so big they're so nuanced
and there are people with strong
opinions on both sides yeah and saying a
short little summary of a big a big a
big nuanced big-picture kind of theme
yeah is is hard because you can't
there's no way to express all your
nuanced feelings about something in a
little sound bite that's one question of
a huge podcast you not I mean yeah
that's true that's something we can say
that we're not religious
yeah we're not religious a lot of people
I would say most people assume that we
were hmm
again I think it's like because we're in
Texas and because we don't curse that
was that a lot of the reasonings given
is that that we were in Texas and
because like we don't curse on our
Channel someone actually thought I was
Mormon like until I was in a tank top
[Laughter]
maybe it's cause like like I don't I
mean I dress kind of conservative way
but it's cuz we're like in the workshop
or like playing video games so of course
I'm just gonna be in like a t-shirt I
want to be comfy yeah I mean there's
that but also I mean like I think that
there are a lot I mean this is getting
into a whole nother subject maybe we
shouldn't even touch on that but like I
don't know like putting yourselves on
the internet is it's a it's an
interesting thing and I think that our
experience with it has been very
positive so far we found an amazing fan
base you guys are so awesome but just
like I was saying with you know seeing a
single sentence about like a complex
subject I think guys can wear almost
whatever they want and they're not gonna
get any flak on the internet no matter
what but girls are somehow subject to
like all this judgment just based on
what they wear which is tricky we're
getting judged for being a shorts guy
yeah but it's just it's just it's just
interesting yeah I don't I typically
don't feel judged I don't think people
judge me for just wearing like t-shirt
and pajama you know yeah that's true I
wear something very neutral yeah it was
interesting to read some of the comments
but but yeah we're we're we're not
religious really um we friends and
family that aren't religious and that
are from very various religions yeah um
you know it's kind of like everybody do
what makes you happy as long as you're
not hurting anybody else you know mmm
moving on to personalities I assume that
because Evan has such a hearty laugh and
big smile that people instantly assume
he's the fun one in the relationship
from Keith Fitz
Kalin's fun I think you're more I think
I'm so I will say like especially
because this is kind of like people
instantly assume so I'm assuming like a
scenario where we're meeting new people
or whoa yeah I think like you are better
in situations with new people at being
instantly like easy to approach and good
with carrying on conversation and I
struggle a little bit more um gets more
flustered I get more flustered and I'm a
little bit more quiet and like if we're
in a situation and like we got separated
I think I have more anxiety about
getting back together because they're
like my safety net this one's strongly
related I've always assumed that you
guys are actually introverts especially
Katelyn you just seem like a shy bunny
we are I would say both more introverted
but I think I am even more yeah I think
you are better learning on the
extraversion when you need to
iiiiii I can be extroverted for periods
of time and it is draining to me and I
can too like I mean we go to events and
stuff and I can be extroverted but I
think like I think the specific thing I
struggle with is like reaching into a
new like oh if I'm like approaching a
circle of people
or something that's near impossible or
like if I'm carrying on a conversation
with someone I don't know super well I'm
not the best at small talking I feel
like you can do that a lot better I can
do that a lot more I think other I don't
know if this is at all related this
might just be my personality and I've
been like this for my entire life like I
do remember when I was younger and my
parents would have dinner party dinner
parties with their like co-workers and
stuff like that ought always just like
be chatting away with them and stuff and
maybe it's because there was a lot of
that in my life like meeting new people
moving a lot having to induce myself to
people otherwise I'll just gonna be like
all alone I mean I had to do that too
yeah but I didn't do as good of a job at
I mean I had like friend groups but like
were you pulled into them or did you
create and push like into something um a
little bit of both a little bit of both
yeah yeah but I also struggled more I
think yeah like I would do the the bare
minimum til I get a small group of
friends and then like I wouldn't really
go too far outside of that at various
iterations of myself and I say that I
could sound strange but like when I
moved out like I was like like what type
of person do I want to become and what
type of person do I want to be so I'd
like kind of test out different like
sides of myself always being true to
myself but like you know I would kind of
see who I wanted to be so it's like I
think that well where did we start with
this and being introverted being
introverted making new group yeah yeah
oh I think I'm a little bit more
introverted than you are there was one
place where and it was like one of the
places wouldn't when I was in California
I just like had I feel bad saying this
and it isn't as sad as it sounds but I
kind of like gave up as much on making
friends because I was like ah we're
gonna move again soon and that's when I
really got into like personal uh
personal digital assistants PDAs and
video games and I like would read Harry
Potter books in the day and like you
know I just read a ton and played a lot
of video games and honestly I think back
on that time is like is pretty fondly
yeah I don't know III like just having
like some me time and just focusing on
myself that's not the worst thing every
now and then yeah and then there were
parts of my life right kind of did try
to become the social hub and that was
nice too
I don't know I would often find myself
actually like latching latching on
sounds bad but I would often become best
friends with the person that was the
social hub mhm and I think that like I
didn't do it on purpose maybe I was just
like attracted to certain types of
friends yeah but like if I look back on
my like best friends throughout the
years it was almost always like you know
whatever girl was like the main party
planner social circle coordinator of the
group but I wonder if it was like oh if
I just put an effort ring friends with
those one person no I don't think so I
don't think I really thought about it
but it's interesting I was good at being
a sidekick like the new person sidekick
let's see I assumed you have very
similar personalities but Evan is more
silly and childish whereas Kalyan is
less so pretty like equally silly there
are times when like we both get to like
extreme silly levels one thing that is
interesting is people assume that we
aren't as silly in real life as we are
on camera and I think that we've
addressed this multiple times but I
think that there are moments where we
are even more silly off camera than we
are on camera now of course like we're
not silly all the time that'd be
exhausting you know all the time for
just working at our desks or you know
yeah I think like in the videos it's
concentrated yeah and I do try to
include if you watch any of our videos
we're not like being silly the entire
time so I think that would be a super
annoying video if it was just like a
hundred percent laughing and yelling and
excitement but you know there are a lot
of like quieter parts where like maybe
we're working on the project and we're
not talking like we just spent some time
like applying finish to a project and we
both put on our headphones and we're
like listening to podcasts energy levels
you know like at this point we are kind
of more
tired and the project has been taking a
long time so we just evaluate discussed
beforehand like hey do you want a
podcaster chat and we just go with that
so this is a funny one
cattle I assume that every 10 minutes
one of you sings a cute or funny short
song like the tin snips songs from the
attic storage right now that is 100%
true it may not be every 10 minutes and
like they go in themes they go in like
and we'll just be singing lots of stuff
to that tune I'll show the majority
background song we have is Christmas
music using a lot of things to the tune
of Christmas songs and to the tunes of
various tick-tocks now yes various in
the past you know a year or so or six
months since I got addicted to tick tock
and like a few like Jimmy we've made up
ourselves that I get repurposed into
whatever we're doing yeah but yeah we
sing yeah tick tock
okay this is interesting ayat from VIN I
assume that in a confrontation with the
stranger Caitlin is the one doing the
fighting willing to go physical and Evan
always has defuse the situation twice
physically confrontational person that's
not true it's not true at all other
efforts are like where we would be more
of like defuse and like get out of there
but we don't find ourselves in
situations where like this is this sound
strange like I would definitely rather
prefer to defuse the situation and stuff
like that but like if if things did get
physical i'll definitely step in like
like like i I get like very upset at the
thought of someone like getting like
confrontational with you like there
aren't many things that upset me my like
I would get very upset if someone like
physically threatened you or something
just let's see
from girl park I assume that people
mistake you guys for being siblings
because I sure as heck did we got
several assumptions related to that we
do get comments sometimes people being
like are they related that's that's
strange to me because because we are
having fun together
we're also we're not super like PDA ish
on videos so I guess you could watch our
videos and not assume that we're in a
relationship I think that's something
that like we generally like like you
know going back to cursing and various
other things we try to like make people
uncomfortable like showing affection is
a bad thing but like I don't know it's
like it's also like what what videos you
film or what people want from you like
setting expectations and everything and
like we want people to just come and
hang out with us not like so we kind of
like act the same way that we would if
we had friends over you're their friends
that's exactly the body each other like
a little hug or a little kiss or
something yeah if someone thought we
were siblings might confusing but yeah I
don't know why do we look like we both
have brown hair
I don't know anyway I don't know but
yeah we do get that sometimes it people
are like are they really okay hmmm from
T Parker I definitely think you guys
would we're hideously fantastic tacky
matching Christmas jumpers I have a
hideously fantastic Christmas jumper
that I wear sometimes but Evan doesn't
and I don't know if they make any in
your size it's really old high school in
terms of matching we do very frequently
wear the same Matt's shirt but that's
because we wear merge shirts all the
time that's my like primary clothing
item that I wear even when we're not
filming honestly yes they're comfortable
they're great they're available at shop
everything Caitlyn calm no but like it's
just it's just I don't want to put much
time and thought into like what I wear
and I know that that's fine and I might
be filming
or whatever that day site is where it's
because I don't want a dirty like two
shirts you know so I don't know yeah
sometimes I do because I used to be like
much more into clothes and shopping and
stuff and sometimes like I do kind of
like what a slight bit more I don't know
like I think it'd be fun to like dress
up slightly more but like it just
doesn't make sense for what we do you
know like I don't want to wear a nice
even my nice stuff is like not that nice
like a slightly fancier t-shirt maybe
it's got an interesting neckline and
some stripes on it boy maybe for some
maybe like for cooking videos like Mertz
if I mess it up yeah I think Kalin's
very practical anything that's that's
why yeah I'm very practical but I did I
did used to get like much joy oh I still
do when there's an occasion but I still
like like getting cute I think you're
cute although thanks baby
I think well yeah baby as we continue
like so we did a cooking video that was
like a different type of video maybe
like if we're doing your makeup well no
then we can get like like makeup dust on
you and stuff but I'm very dusty make
you older like spray dust on you okay
this one is this is so interesting BBG
assume is that you guys are extremely
chill and lazy couple that isn't super
adventurous would you consider jumping
out of airplanes adventurous or scuba
diving shaprut or scuba diving or going
canyoning yeah because like generally we
are trouble putting your jobs to start a
youtube channel we are pretty chill but
we are also adventurous and not in any
way we we struggle with taking breaks
pretty significantly like to the point
where it might be slightly detrimental
so we have a really hard time being lazy
now this is something that I would say
if I think that I do have like a
generally lazier personality but at the
same time
I have a strong commitment to follow
through with things I start and we have
started so many YouTube channels and
that takes an ongoing commitment that
you have to keep up with there's
expectations all over the place their
sponsors and there's commitments and
like I take that very seriously but
generally I think that I would be lazier
if it wasn't for all of that and that
what if it wasn't for like the value
that we were building there like
strength of our brand for the future of
the channel all of that and like what it
the security that it provides for us and
all these other things but at the same
time like I worked really hard at all my
jobs to ya didn't provide that yeah and
all these other things so I think we
have a hard time not being productive in
some way we can do it for like like we
can like take a break at the end of the
night - like I'll read and like you'll
play some minecraft or something no like
an hour I'll say when I was when I was
single for a little bit before dating
you I sometimes would like take a whole
day and play video games all day long
like on a Saturday or something I'll
just play video games all day long I
remember I played like Skyrim like well
one day and I just played Skyrim all day
and like honestly by the end if it I was
a little bit grossed out with myself I
just like ate ramen and cereal and
takeout and stuff kasra mmm
any rice but well I I don't want to do
that much that's like yeah yeah I don't
really know where I was going with that
but yeah I would I would say um I don't
think you can have a YouTube channel
that you're doing full-time and also be
lazy yeah hey you could maybe have be a
little bit lazy if you've gotten
yourself to a point where like maybe you
can take weekends off but we are far
from being able to take what you can off
now I think that like interestingly of
all of the crazy thing which we've done
scuba diving jumping out of airplanes
and parachuting parachuting ooh
caved Oh skydiving skydiving cave dive
cave diving tubing cave tubing canyoning
oh I'm sea cave boating you only went to
the sea caves yeah oh yeah that was
crazy mostly on vacations cuz yeah
but I think of all of that the biggest
most exciting most rewarding adventure
we've been on it sounds so corny but I'm
corny person is starting this YouTube
channel with you yeah it's been the most
exciting the most rewarding the most
like fulfilling like like like the
memories we've made doing this and
everything and and just the whole
adventure of it is is has been so
exciting and having someone to share it
with I certainly wouldn't be able to do
this by myself no way not just the
workload because both of us exhausting -
emotionally exhausting and like I
wouldn't I I don't
it'd be much harder to share the true
joy of all the wins with someone who
wasn't doing it with you know I could be
completely wrong because we're not
we've never been in that situation but
like it's been so great sharing all the
successes with someone who knows how
much went into this and when things go
wrong we can talk each other out of that
stress yeah well I think we might need
to wrap up the assumptions for now we
still have so many we didn't even get to
a third no we still have so many
assumptions about when we were younger
about our social lives about our home
life about our work about our
relationship we maybe hit a quarter of
them so we're gonna go into our thing of
the week but if you guys liked this let
us know we would love to answer more of
these because there's a lot of very
fascinating ones that I would I think it
would be fun to address it's so
interesting to see the assumptions this
is a great topic this is a great topic
and we all we acknowledge that this
isn't something that like we came up
with originally on YouTube very like we
didn't get it from a single individual
person it's just like we see it a lot
you should we should do that too so yeah
oh it's interesting okay do you want to
go with your youtube recommendation all
to a product recommendation singer Louie
cue music
okay so my thing of the week is a
channel that popped up on our homepage
and I think it's because we watch a lot
of Drew Gooden and Kenny comes I was
like because he watches drool and danny
gonzalez that got like helped us find
him but his name is Jarvis Johnson um
and he does like just very funny
commentary if you like Drew or Danny's
channels I think you'll like Jarvis's
channel right like dry commentary
Inhumans tons of I respect the pun game
very much and I would say like if you if
you're looking somewhere to start on his
channel he does some really hilarious
like commentaries on really bad reality
TV so like the bachelor/bachelorette
ones the love is blind but he also feels
like you like commentary on YouTube
drama or like just like all sorts of
like weird sketchy YouTube channels Oh
which there are loss yes but um but
we've been liking his his videos we've
been kind of binge watching and my thing
of the week is something that I got from
for myself because I kept on stealin
kaitlin's yeah so um a while ago it's
like cuz I worked at a company that like
had like a person that went around and
helped you be economic at work which I
should like get back into my organ AMA
care yeah I should I should be better
ergonomically look I am perfectly
economic now hut Kalyan has some bad
organ Amma Cabot's at a desk and we
spend so much of our time at desks you
know like majority of most the majority
of our work time is at desks especially
Kaitlyn because she edits them you know
and she we have a lot of anyways there's
this is besides the point but um you
know so I've had a lot of like urgh
anomic habits drilled into me and one
thing that I see that have seen that has
helped with sitting properly at a desk
is you get a little footrest for your
feet and that kind of helps align your
whole body it you know you can look up
like proper ergonomic postures online
but anyway so this is a little footrest
and I kept I'm stealing Kaitlyn so I got
one for myself finally so now
both have little feet rest and if
sitting at a desk is something that you
do a lot you should maybe look into a
footrest and also raising your monitor
up higher because that's the other big
but I see a lot of people not doing well
in terms of their ergonomic looking down
at monitors bad straight neck the top of
your monitor should be about level with
your eyes when you're sitting up
straight and the footrest specifically
it's um so it's a little freestanding
thing it's like a little like a little
foam cushion that's domed on top and it
has little grippy things on the other
underside so doesn't slide it's very
lightweight easy to keep under your desk
easy to like scooch out of the way when
you don't want it and like pull back
with one socked foot when you do want it
yeah it's pretty sweet we both have one
I think that five I know
really I hope you guys liked this
episode because I really want to react
an answer to more of the assumptions I
don't like it will still do it hope you
enjoyed it and as always we really
appreciate seeing those reviews that are
always a great pick pick us up if we're
having a bad day we just like looking at
the podcast reviews because they're the
most wholesome thing so if you are so
feeling inclined you can leave us a
review on the Apple iTunes Store it
helps people find us but I'm not sure
what people would do if they found our
broadcast on like iTunes that'd be so
confused or like who are these people
and why are they talking about these
things who cares anyway let's confuse
people podcast in the ranks so that
people who don't know it's fine hi guys
hope you're having a good day we'll see
you next time
[Music]